[Music]
the saudis have exported more extremist
ideology than any other place on earth
over the last 30 years
this quote is from hillary clinton
however at the same time this former
secretary of state authorized the sale
of arms to saudi arabia and you'll say
really well what a hypocrite but did you
know that bin laden himself
even threatened the saudi royal house in
2003. it may surprise you but saudi
arabia was the first country
interested in ending islamic terrorism
and at the same time one of its greatest
promoters and i want you to remember
this video well because everything
indicates that the story we are going to
tell you today could be one of our
greatest nightmares for the coming
decade
that of the 1920s in the 21st century so
what is happening in saudi arabia and
why should the whole world be concerned
in this video we are going to tell you
[Applause]
[Music]
when we think of the saudis we think of
oil mountains of money
and the most extravagant luxuries but
what if i told you that this country is
actually on the verge of bankruptcy
we've told you a thousand times here on
visualpolitik
saudi arabia has been heading for
economic collapse for years
its economy is completely dependent on
oil exports dinosaur jews has paid for
the whims of saudi princes but also for
the salaries of almost all of its
citizens who work as civil servants in a
way
we could say that the saudis have lived
a utopian dream for decades
to live without hardly working without
paying taxes and with more than generous
salaries
but as oil prices drop the whole system
is coming down and yes
the coronavirus has been a catalyst for
this phenomenon
and i know what many of you are thinking
why should i care i have enough problems
to worry about
to be concerned with what's going on in
saudi arabia well you should be
concerned
very concerned much of saudi society is
very prone to embracing radical islam
in addition its population is very young
so they have a lot of people old enough
to join terrorist groups the most
worrying thing is that saudi arabia has
the third most expensive and modern
military arsenal in the world
only behind the united states and china
imagine what could happen if all of this
fell into the wrong hands
[Music]
in other words today saudi arabia is
already funding
islamic radicalism around the world many
saudi millionaires are paying for
radical mosques and schools all over the
globe including europe and the united
states and the saudi government
doesn't really know how to avoid it so
the question we're asking today
is what is the root of this problem why
is the solution so difficult and why
might it become
our worst nightmare in the years to come
today we are going to answer these
questions
first let's take a look at some history
[Music]
the saudi ideological gap in the 18th
century
what we know today as saudi arabia was a
desert controlled by different empires
mainly the ottoman one a lot of nomadic
bedouin tribes with more or less power
lived in these lands in different
territories one of them was the dynasty
of the swords
who dominated the territory surrounding
modern day riot
at the time the sauds were already very
religious the patriarchs of this dynasty
had reached a kind of pact they would be
in charge of military affairs but the
day-to-day affairs would be regulated by
the clergy more specifically the
followers of a very specific theologian
muhammad ibn abd al-wahab and yes we are
talking about the father of what we know
today as salafism salafism is a very
orthodox interpretation of islam
and above all it's very austere for
example have you noticed that even today
saudi princes always wear the same
clothes
[Music]
take a good look beard tunic headscarf
and sandals
this attire is not by chance salafists
must dress according to tradition
both men and women should be modest that
is to say they cannot display vanity
and that is why you will rarely see a
saudi arabian prince wearing a giorgio
armani suit
even if he has the money to buy as many
as he wants well the followers of this
theologian were supported by the saudi
nobles who
as we mentioned dominated a very small
region of what is now
saudi arabia however in the 1930s all
these arab tribes went to war for
control of the entire arabian peninsula
the united kingdom supported the saudis
with this help the royal house of saud
took
control of almost the entire peninsula
in 1932 and this is how the great arab
nation that we know today as saudi
arabia with its first king was born
[Applause]
in the beginning this new country was a
poor land the nomadic tribes and little
more than the desert but in 1938
things changed forever
that was the year when saudi arabia
discovered that it was sitting
on a whole sea of oil the u.s oil
companies started to exploit it and
in the process make agreements with the
saudi royal house overnight
this dynasty of nomadic bedouins became
millionaires on a side note when we talk
about the saudi royal family you're
probably thinking of a small family the
parents the children
and a few courtiers right well look at
this today the saudi royal family is
estimated to have about
fifteen thousand members of whom around
two thousand hold political power and
mountains of petrodollars
to give you an idea about how that came
about the first saudi king king
abdulaziz
had 17 wives and 45 children curiously
none of those children has inherited the
throne
from 1932 until today all the kings of
this country had been the brothers of
this first king but let's get on with
our story
suddenly the saudi princes have become
millionaires and what do you do when you
have money
literally dripping out of stones you
spend it as if there were no tomorrow
this is when the whole world begins to
notice the arab shakes for their most
extravagant luxuries
mansions all over the planet expensive
cars and luxury parties
but wait a minute didn't we say that
salafism preaches modesty well
yes you're right and that explains why
it is in these years when the great
ideological gap begins
in saudi arabia while the saudi royal
house was discovering the advantages of
being millionaires the salafist clerics
were criticizing them from their mosques
and so we come to 1979. the year in
which
this happens
[Music]
mecca 1979 the mosque siege that changed
the course of saudi history
bbc probably very few of you know this
story but it is a turning point in the
history of saudi arabia
one of the most important mosques in the
world is the great mosque of mecca well
in 1979
groups of radical salafists took over
this mosque
according to them the whole country had
forgotten its religious roots more than
50 000 saudi arabian army commandos had
to enter to free the mosque and more
than 250 people died by the way as a
side note i can tell you that this same
mosque had been restored
by a builder from bin laden's family
well at the time of the attack the saudi
royal house faced a tremendous moral
dilemma on the one hand
they liked luxury more than anything
else and on the other hand they
themselves believed in the orthodox and
austere principles of salafis of the
outcome
firstly they paid attention to the most
extreme demands of the religious that's
when they brought out laws like the one
that forbade women to drive
but secondly they kept living their
lifestyle to the max in fact a year
later in 1980 was when the
nationalization of aramco the saudi oil
company was completed
at that time the saudi royal house was
making more money than ever
and that's when we entered the period
off
[Music]
the double standard now the question
that i'm sure many of you have pondered
is
what would you do if you suddenly
started making billions of dollars as if
there were no tomorrow well the saudi
royal house has the answer spend all of
that money on the craziest luxuries that
you can imagine for example
one of those 2 000 saudi princes had a
custom mercedes made covered entirely
with diamonds
others however preferred to spend their
cash on other things such as political
and religious influence
and that's why starting in the 1970s
many of these saudi billionaires began
giving money to travis these charities
have built salafist schools and mosques
throughout the islamic world and the
non-islamic one too today there are
salafist mosques in practically every
country
what began as a minority religious
denomination is becoming a widely
accepted
belief it is gaining ground in places as
disparate as dagestan or chechnya as
well of course as muslim communities in
countries like france
and as you know we're not just talking
about religion many of these salafist
mosques not only discuss religion but
they also promote terrorism
today we can say that much of the money
that was used to plan september 11
came from saudi millionaires but hold on
a minute because the united states is
not the only enemy of the salafist
terrorists
in fact their worst enemy is what they
consider false
salafists bin laden himself launched
messages against the saudi royal house
and in so in 2008 the saudi arabian
government signed an agreement with the
white house to fight terrorism
and since then saudi arabia has come to
create its own centers of
de-radicalization
in these centers islamic radicals
conduct art therapy sessions group
dynamics and all kinds of treatments
very similar to those used to treat drug
addiction the effectiveness of these
treatments is
debatable to say the least meanwhile the
united states has sent advisors
shared intelligence and sold all kinds
of weapons to saudi arabia and you're
probably thinking
hang on what's with all this weaponry
well in many cases things like this
happen
the us shipped weapons and secrets to
the saudis and emiratis
now some of these are in the hands of
fighters linked to al-qaeda
and iran cnn at this point some may
think that all this is because saudi
arabia does not want to end terrorism
but what if it boiled down to simple
inefficiency think about it the saudi
royal family has 2 000 princes with
money and royal power so much money in
power that they can afford to live on
the fringes of government do you really
think society is so easy to control well
not really in fact
for the moment the only strategy that
has allowed the saudi monarchs to
control their society
is this
the saudi social contract to better
understand how society works in saudi
arabia let's look at this chart
the working population represents 59 of
the country so far so good well
more than half of those workers are
immigrants the other half are saudi
nationals well
of these national workers more than 70
of civil servants that's right
practically all saudi citizens work for
the government under superb conditions
an average salary of between three
thousand
and four thousand dollars practically
tax-free in addition
most of their expenses are subsidized
that includes housing
and of course in most cases saudi
officials do not even have to comply
with working hours
in other words the saudi social contract
is very simple you turn a blind eye to
all the luxuries of the saudi royal
house and in return we allow you to live
in utopia this strategy became even more
evident in 2011. like the rest of the
muslim countries
saudi arabia also had its own particular
arabian spring with protests in the
streets so how did the government
respond
simple the king launched a 93 billion
dollar spending package comprising
public housing and new civil service
positions
and how do you pay for all this when you
barely charge any taxes you know the
answer dinosaur juice oil has financed a
real economic utopia meanwhile the saudi
royal house has bought the most modern
weaponry on the planet
[Music]
fighter planes tanks and everything else
that you can imagine the saudi arabian
army is the third most expensive army in
the world
in 2017 trump authorised 110 billion
dollars in arms sales to give you an
idea this figure is roughly equivalent
to morocco's entire gdp well over the
next seven years the saudi royal house
is going to spend all this money on
armaments and you will say
why is the united states so interested
in selling arms to this country the idea
is that with so much weaponry saudi
arabia can fight terrorism in fact in
2015 riyadh created a
whole military coalition against
terrorism a kind of anti-terrorist nato
that includes almost all muslim
countries
all except iran of course however we
return to our original point
how can you control all those 2 thousand
princes of the saudi royal house
many of them are the first ones to
finance terrorism but at the same time
they are part of the elite that governs
the country however this is not saudi
arabia's biggest problem the biggest
problem in this country is that this
saudi social pact is about to be broken
because the price of oil is no longer
what it used to be
fewer and fewer petrov dollars are
entering the country and everything
points to this being a continuing trend
in the coming decades
well in 2017 the solution to all these
problems had a name of its own listen up
the great saudi disappointment since
2017 muhammad bin salman has been the
crown prince of saudi arabia that is
when his father king salman dies
he will inherit the throne but until
that day comes he already has full
powers to run the country
think about it ben solomon is 35 years
old his father is 84. the objective of
this young prince is to succeed in
diversifying the saudi arabian economy
in other words this saudi social pact
will no longer depend on the price of
oil
[Music]
for that he needs to create new economic
sectors and that explains all the mega
projects that we have talked about in
previous visualpolitik videos but not
only that
do you remember those 2 000 members of
the saudi royal house well many of them
are not at all happy to be directed by a
35 year old boy
much less with hearing about
modernisation in their country and
that's why
from the first day that bin salman took
power he decided to strike
[Music]
how saudi elite became five-star
prisoners at the riyadh
ritz-carlton telegraph exactly bin
salman didn't even break a sweat when he
launched anti-corruption raids across
the country in three years
he's shown everyone who is in charge of
this country in other words saudi arabia
has gone from having a quasi-tribal
political system to becoming
a one-person dictatorship this also
explains the murder of journalists jamal
khashoggi and many other activists these
are all attempts by bin salman to
consolidate his power
many of these actions are real
monstrosities however the white house
has turned a blind eye why because at
least in theory
thanks to these movements bin salman can
control the most radical religious
leaders
and here is where the dilemma lies which
is better do we accept that bin salman
becomes a dictator in exchange for saudi
arabia stopping the export of terrorism
well yes it could be a major ethical
dilemma but don't worry you can stop
wondering
reality has already given us the answer
bin salman is failing
miserably
the clearest example is in the yemen war
saudi arabia has the most modern
weaponry in the world yemeni rebels
supported by iran use soviet union
weaponry in principle
this war would seem like a military tour
de force however the yemen war has
become a humanitarian drama and a
complete humiliation for saudi arabia
meanwhile in the field of economics bin
salman has applied
the recipes of the swedish chef we have
explained it in many other videos that
i'll link for you in the description the
aramco ipo
was a failure and almost no investor has
dared to take a gamble on the saudi mega
cities you know those mega cities that
we're going to have flying cars jurassic
parks and artificial moons to attract
tourism to all this we must add the
coronavirus crisis which has acted as a
catalyst
meanwhile bin salman is depleting
foreign reserve currencies and
increasing the country's debt
at the same time youth unemployment in
saudi arabia is already at 27
think about it with a state on the verge
of bankruptcy is it possible to hire
more officials
at the same time all of this was
happening bin salman bought one of the
most expensive yachts in the world
a luxury yacht worth more than half a
billion dollars in addition he has a 300
million dollar french castle and a 450
million
davinci painting in other words more and
more young people are going on to
unemployment benefits
meanwhile despite bin salman's efforts
there are still plenty of radical imams
preaching their ideas on social networks
some like muhammad al-arif have over 20
million followers on twitter this man is
banned from countries such as
switzerland denmark and the united
kingdom
however he still works at king saud
university
[Music]
the saudi government has tried to stop
him on several occasions and in each of
these attempts
thousands of supporters took to the
streets to defend him to top it off
remember the enormous arsenal that the
saudi army has
and here's where we have some questions
for you what would happen if all those
weapons
fell into the wrong hands what would
happen if the saudi social contract was
definitively broken
what would happen if all those saudi
citizens lost their jobs leave your
answers
down in the comments so i really hope
you enjoyed this video please hit like
if you did and don't forget to subscribe
for brand new videos don't forget to
check out our friends at the reconsider
media podcast they provided the vocals
in this episode that were not mine
and also this channel is possible
because of patreon and our patrons on
that platform please consider joining
them and supporting our mission of
providing independent political coverage
as always
i'll see you in the next video and if
you want to learn more about politics
and hear even more of my lovely voice
you can join us at reconsider media we
have a podcast at reconsider media.com
podcast see you there